show me the giant robots
this monstrous machine is supercharging
puppets
to the max this is a real-life
transformer it's what I call a major
minor we caught up with trailblazing
puppeteer hell Sylvester to find out
what inspired his big well huge idea
he's called the manager because he's
partway between man and engine he's the
ultimate mining machine the way we've
refined and refined and refined all the
controls gives the the puppet a lot of
grace and sensitivity even though he's a
big beefy bore tongue lump of Steel
suddenly it was there was this moment
we've create something and it's it is
come alive but to land a place in
game-changers how scaling up a man
engine to its limits standing either 33
feet tall that's over 10 meters high
this is the biggest mechanical puppet
the United Kingdom has ever seen there
are a couple different ways of building
machines that move heavy things around
this machine uses hydraulics hydraulic
machines hump around in compressible
fluids in this case oil that oil is used
to move hydraulic Pistons the motion of
those Pistons moves Muppet the puppets
attached to a construction front-end
loader the front bucket has been removed
and replaced with a puppet the operator
sits in the cab of the front-end loader
and controls the standing up of the
puppet from there hydraulics are
powerful but they're not graceful not
every part of this puppet should be
controlled in that way and so there are
ten additional puppeteers using ropes
those ropes go through pulleys and
cranks and levers and they're able to
move the arms head and the rest of the
puppet with such fluid motions
we didn't want to get in that a
completely hydraulic puppet because it
looked like a robot and we wanted to see
the labor because because mining is is
full of endeavor we wanted to see the
labor and the sweat of people pulling on
raped what this team has done is taken
industrial equipment and created a
beautiful engineering spectacle so even
though this is a bunch of steel and
metal and smoke it's a graceful thing to
watch
you